hi guys welcome to this video on the
interview questions of configuration
management tools chef and symbol and
puppet chef is a configuration
management tool written in Ruby and Earl
and which provides continuous deployment
increases system robustness and provides
cloud integration ansible is another
open source software tool for
provisioning configuration management
and application deployment and puppet is
a configuration management tool that can
also be used as a deployment tool and
implements infrastructure as a code in
this video we have compiled the most
important interview questions of
configuration management tools
chef ansible and puppet that you might
face in a divorce interview so without
further ado let's get started so let's
just get into their first section which
is configuration management so one of
the questions that you'll get asked
right away is why do you have SSL
certificates used for chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security SSL provides for a
very high level of private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using SSL and
you're using the private public key
model within SSL you're able to
guarantee the system's on your network
that the chef that you'll be able to
validate that the nodes within your
network that chef is validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters so you will also be asked
some questions and such as the following
which is the following commands would
you use to stop or disable the HTTP
servers when the system boots and you'll
typically get four responses and
there'll be hash tag systemctl disable
httpd service or is its system disabled
HTTP service system disabled HTTP D or
the final option which is systemctl
disable HTTP de dot service your answer
should be the first one which is hash
tag system CTL disable HTTP server
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allow its to function effectively
and one of the tools that you're gonna
be asked about is what is Test Kitchen
and Test Kitchen is essentially a
command-line tool that allows you to be
able to test out your cookbook before
you actually deploy it to a real note so
some of the commands that you would use
are for instance if you want to create
an instance of Test Kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine multiple instances you
would do kitchen converge so question
you'll get is around chef is how does
chef apply differ from chef client and
so fundamentally the difference between
them is that chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client looks to apply
invalidate the entire cookbook that's
run in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook so there
are some differences when you're working
with different command lines so for
instance I'm when you're working with
puppets and you're working with one
version of puppet and you want to do
what is the command to sign a requested
certificate the top example here is for
puppet version 2.7 whereas the lower
option here is for puppet version 3 and
I something to bear in mind when you're
going through your interview process is
that the tools that are used within a
continuous integration continuous
delivery DevOps model do vary and so you
want to be able to talk knowledgeably
about the different versions of the
tools so that when you're talking to
your interviewer you're able to show you
the deep knowledge that you have which
open-source or community tools do you
use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is are being able
to track configurations with JIRA which
you should be doing anyway but it's a
great way to be able to clearly
communicate the work that's being done
with puppet a version control can be
extended with get and then the changes
should be
passthrough jenkins so the three tools
you want to be looking at integration
with JIRA git and Jenkins so what are
the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic unit of any
configuration management tool
they are the features of the nodes they
are the written catalog and the
execution or the catalog on a node so as
we dig deeper into puppet one of the
things that you are likely to be asked
regarding puppet is what is a class in
puppet and so a class and puppet is
really the name blocks in your manifest
that contain the various configurations
and listen can include services files
and packages and we have on the screen
here example of what a class would look
like when you write it out and you may
want to memorize just one class don't
memorize just a whole set of classes
just memorize one the person that's
intervening you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around as well is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install Tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about answer both
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference and
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as French
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within an sport and really
the answer comes down into two things
one is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables in the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have food and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include sub-module
or another file in your playbook the
second is to import an improvement of an
include which ensures that a final is
added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at as well
it's a very easy agentless installation
it's based on Python you can configure
it with llamó and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
Ruby the configuration files are written
in DSL and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture and so it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push
only architecture and contrast to puppet
it's a more complicated but more
sophisticated architecture where you're
able to have a complete environment
managed by the puppet architecture with
that we've reached the end of this video
on the interview questions of
configuration management tools
chef ansible and puppet I hope you
enjoyed this video do like and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here